apparently there's a ghost wolf near
mount fuji that i want to go and
discover
ghosts in japan yeah a few hundred years
ago there we go
yeah they were well no they all went
extinct yeah well
apparently in the district near mount
fuji amongst the tallest mountains in
the country 3000 meters some nights you
could hear like a howl
of a wolf and they call him the ghost
wolf and i want to go and find it in the
video
or just discover a trash taste special
i'll do the drain
you just want to use it she just want to
talk everything goes back to the drone
like [ __ ] krakatoa doesn't it imagine
one of you getting eaten in the drone
shot
i come with a drone by a ghost
especially
360 drones getting ripped apart by a
wolf
why is this a war for ghost wolf because
no one's seen it
the mountains because because all the
wolves all the wolves in japan have gone
extinct
you want us to go and film a ghost that
uh a wolf that no one has ever seen
the hood i've heard it what are we gonna
film there's nothing in the [ __ ]
point you go into the [ __ ] mountains
with a baseball bat just redo some kind
of like ghost hunters
i feel like it's presence oh the ghost
wolf is entering
it's like you just have a [ __ ]
[ __ ] seance at the top of the
mountain
chris just walk around and be like oh
[ __ ] oh it's trees
it's good content you know it is it's
not [ __ ] good it is no one's going to
watch the best cases
horror videos are like we're going to go
to someplace haunted and all they do is
just like [ __ ] scream and like
nut everywhere every 10 seconds i
thought of a ghost best case you find
the wolf you get an instagram selfie
worst case
yeah i think that would be like
international [ __ ] recognized as
heroes of wars
heroes of wolves heroes of wars the wolf
hero do you have what's in the uk
no we should foxes right yeah we have
foxes which are just like virgin wolves
i mean that's that's kind of what chad's
just nerfed wolves
[Music]
talk he's like guys i found it i don't
know i saw i saw some
mountain people used to climb up in
japan some horror video about it they
just a bunch of people climbed up the
mountain and just never came back
and they made like an sos sign in like
the mountain what
and then they rescued someone on the
mountain and they're like oh we found
you because you've s
your sos sign they're like what sos sign
oh god play scary music
too much volcanoes those damn ghost
wolves just making something
i don't want to go on any japanese
mountain alone ghost wolves